[Música]
pasivo de poder en sri lanka los
manifestantes irrumpieron en la
residencia del Primer Ministro ahora
designado como presidente interino tras
la huida del país del mandatario
botavaya los ciudadanos exigen también
la renuncia del premiere quien pidió a
las fuerzas militares que restauren el
orden en el país
el presidente de Estados Unidos Joe
biden comenzó su primer viaje por medio
oriente y aterrizó en Israel Espera que
el mandatario fortalezca las relaciones
militares con ese estado también viajará
a territorios palestinos y Arabia
Saudita
garantizar la exportación de cereales
desde Ucrania a través del mar Negro Ese
es el objetivo de la reunión que
adelantaron hoy los ucranianos y los
rusos con la intermediación de Turquía y
la ONU se espera que la otra semana haya
un acuerdo
Bienvenidos a las noticias de Franz 24
yo soy María Clara calle Gracias por
estar con nosotros comenzamos en sri
lanka donde se agrava el vacío de poder
el presidente gotabaya raya parcha
todavía no ha presentado oficialmente su
renuncia al parlamento a pesar de que
había dicho que este miércoles lo haría
raya patxi a huyó del país y hasta ahora
se conoce que está en las islas maldivas
buscando una nación donde exiliarse el
Primer Ministro running wiccreme Singer
que dejó el mandatario como presidente
interino pidió a las fuerzas militares
hacerlo necesario para restaurar el
orden después de que cientos de
manifestantes se tomaran la residencia
del Primer Ministro exigiéndole que
también renuncien conectamos a esta hora
con Alejandro Godoy experto en política
y economía de Asia señor Godoy
Bienvenido a Franz 24 empecemos hablando
sobre cuál fue el punto de quiebre para
que esta semana del presidente de Bogotá
vaya rayapacha huyera del país y
afirmara que va a renunciar es el de la
era de los raya patxi dictando los
destinos de sri lanka
sí es un momento muy relevante sobre
todo porque su hermano Brasil tener al
ministro de finanzas ya desde el mes de
marzo había renunciado Eso quiere decir
que se establece en una dinámica
supremamente importante
en cuanto a la imposibilidad que ellos
sigan en el poder Es bien interesante
también porque ya los partidos políticos
del parlamento entre ellos poder
político con otros líderes supremamente
relevantes como es el caso específico de
quien conocemos con el nombre del plan
de maduro abandara han establecido ya
que van a hacer un gobierno interino y
que el Premier quien está en el momento
en el poder debe abandonarlo totalmente
para poder seguir con una transición en
momentos tan complejos como sabemos como
una crisis que se establece
prácticamente de forma alimentaria bueno
y el pueblo parece decidido a lograr
cambios pero ante esta ola de protestas
y los aliados de los raya patxi aún en
el poder hay riesgos de una espiral de
violencia
totalmente sobre todo porque nos
encontramos ante una Tormenta perfecta
donde no tienen gasolina no tienen
materias primas no tienen alimentos y
como lo hemos visto en otras
revoluciones a lo largo de la historia y
en las más cercanas cuando la gente está
con un nivel de descontrol tan fuerte
pues y donde vemos unas violaciones
masivas de los Derechos Humanos en este
contexto lo que encontramos es la
gasolina totalmente puesta sobre la mesa
para entrar entrar en un momento van a
ver qué rico que es lo que no se quiere
dar eso es fundamentalmente lo que
encontramos y qué necesita sri lanka
para salir de la crisis económica y
política en la que se encuentra
es muy complejo porque es un tema
estructural que lo vemos Ya de varias
décadas Tuvo una guerra civil entre 1983
y 2009 Pero de igual manera también la
mano amiga de unos gobiernos muy
cercanos entre los cuales ya se ve India
el fondo monetario internacional sobre
una negociación pero sobre todo Hablamos
de una deuda superior a los 51 mil
millones de dólares Por ende serán meses
supremamente complejos y más que meses
años donde tendrán que aumentar todos
los temas de impuestos Y esto no va a
gustar nada a la población
meses complejos para sri lanka es lo que
nos dice Alejandro Godoy Alejandro
Gracias por estar con nosotros en
francés 24
gracias a ustedes y cambiamos de noticia
comenzó el primer viaje del presidente
de Estados Unidos Joe biden por medio
oriente hoy aterrizó en Israel y Desde
allí habló en contra del programa
nuclear de Irán se espera que bailen
haga una declaración conjunta con los
israelíes sobre los lazos militares
luego el mandatario viajará a
territorios palestinos y Arabia Saudita
la visita de un viejo amigo el
presidente de Estados Unidos Joe biden
llegó a Israel en su primera visita
desde que llegó a la casa blanca en 2021
una bienvenida cargada de referencias
bíblicas y con constantes alusiones a la
profunda y sólida relación de ambos
países
su relación con Israel siempre ha sido
muy personal una vez usted se proclamó
como un sionista y dijo que no tenía que
ser judío para ser un sionista y tenía
razón
lo digo nuevamente no necesita ser judío
para hacer un sionista Esta es mi décima
visita y cada vez que tengo la
oportunidad de regresar a este país
donde las raíces del pueblo judío se
remontan a tiempos bíblicos es una
bendición porque la conexión entre el
pueblo israelillo el pueblo
estadounidense es fuerte y profunda
pero con una visita Jerusalén estesis
Jordania también Busca reafirmar a los
palestinos que Estados Unidos está
comprometido con una solución de dos
estados mientras espera promover la
estabilidad en medio oriente profundizar
la integración de Israel en la región y
contrarrestar la influencia iraní este
mismo miércoles antes de su llegada la
Casa Blanca informó sobre un acuerdo
entre tel aviv y Washington que busca la
cooperación para la innovación
tecnológica una alianza que plantea
soluciones a desafíos globales como el
cambio climático la medicina y la
agricultura
somos temas de seguridad Nacional
discutiremos sobre construir una nueva
arquitectura económica para las naciones
del medio oriente siguiendo los acuerdos
de Abraham y los logros de la Cumbre de
negué
luego de reunirse con el presidente de
la autoridad nacional Palestina en
cisjordania ocupada el viernes se espera
que bailen aterricen Arabia Saudita y le
pida al monarca de riad que impulse a
los Aliados del Golfo para que amplíen
la producción de petróleo se genere más
oferta con mayores extracciones y así se
reduzca el precio de la gasolina
inflados por la guerra en Ucrania
y mientras el presidente viaja en su por
a través de medio oriente la inflación
interanual en Estados Unidos aumentó a
un 9,1% en junio Este es el mayor
incremento que ha habido en 40 años lo
que significa que los estadounidenses
han tenido que pagar más por la gasolina
los alimentos y varios servicios la
respuesta fue que los mercados cerraron
con pérdidas ante los temores de una
acción más agresiva por parte de la
reserva Federal desde Washington nuestro
corresponsal Cristóbal Vázquez nos
ampliaba previamente la información
mientras que wden está de visita en el
medio oriente hay malas noticias
económicas en casa la inflación vuelve a
registrar otro
récord en junio los precios de los
productos y los servicios básicos
subieron un 9,1% en Estados Unidos en
comparación con el mismo mes del año
anterior una cifra alarmante teniendo en
cuenta que en mayo La inflación era del
8,6%. el alza en los precios de la
gasolina la subida precipitada en
alquiler y los altos precios de la
comida catapultaron la inflación los más
afectados han sido Y seguirán siendo la
clase media y las minorías hispanas y
afroamericanas que destinan la mayoría
de sus recursos a la renta el transporte
y la comida según economistas la
situación llevará que la reserva Federal
tenga que subir más rápido sus tasas de
interés para tratar de controlar la
inflación al atraer el dinero circulante
que está calentando la economía hecho
que podría llevar a una recesión
económica el próximo año como lo dicen
Algunos analistas porque esto llevaría a
que el costo de endeudamiento sea alto y
termine afectando la inversión y la
producción en Estados Unidos
otra de las noticias en Estados Unidos
Fue la publicación de un video sobre la
inacción de la policía el día del
tiroteo de uvalde en Texas en las
imágenes difundidas por los medios de
comunicación locales se puede ver que
los agentes esperaron más de una hora
antes de intervenir contra el tirador
quien asesinó a 19 niños y a dos
maestras en una escuela el 24 de mayo
las familias de las víctimas expresaron
su rabia e indignación los detalles en
el siguiente informe
la falta de acción de la policía ante el
atacante que mató a 19 niños y dos
profesoras en una escuela de uvalde en
Texas el pasado 24 de mayo quedó en
evidencia en un video difundido por
medios de comunicación locales
para ser sincero no sé si realmente
quiero verlo no puede ser bonito no
puede ser agradable Así que
probablemente veré todo lo que pueda
pero no lo quiero
de lo que he visto en las noticias estos
agentes todos estos oficiales tenían sus
escudos sus armas todo su equipo de
protección y no hicieron nada no
hicieron nada el video comienza con la
llegada del atacante a las 11:33 de la
mañana en una esquina del pasillo
aparece un niño quien lo ve a apuntar su
arma a un salón de clase y abrir fuego
a partir de este momento los disparos se
suceden durante tres minutos hasta que
llegan los primeros policías a las 11:36
se dirigen hacia el aula pero oyendo los
disparos se retiran a una esquina
36 minutos después siguen en el mismo
lugar
uno de ellos Incluso se sirve gel
hidroalcogólico un detalle condenatorio
comentado en Twitter por la fundadora
demont action una organización que hace
campaña por una regulación más estricta
de las armas the statesman acaba de
publicar las imágenes de vigilancia del
tiroteo masivo en una escuela de uvalde
en las que se ve a la policía con equipo
de balística esperando en el pasillo de
la escuela e incluso parándose para
ponerse gel desinfectante mientras los
niños y las profesoras son masacrados a
las 12:50 se escuchan disparos un equipo
a finalmente matado al asesino varias
investigaciones fueron abiertas sobre el
papel de la policía de la masacre pero
sus conclusiones no se han hecho
públicas Ahora nos vamos a Ucrania los
rusos se ejecutaron una serie de
bombardeos en el sur del país en la
ciudad de Nicolás mataron a al menos a
cinco personas y en saprilla dos misiles
impactaron una fábrica hiriendo a 14
personas esto ratifica la intención de
Moscú de ganar poder en el sur ucraniano
a la par que refuerza su presencia en el
este hoy en la provincia de doñaesc la
ciudad de bagmut fue duramente
bombardeada por otra parte Corea del
Norte reconoció a las autoproclamadas
repúblicas independientes del lugar
idóneasca un estatus que solo han
reconocido Rusia y Siria lo que llevó
aquí es a romper relaciones diplomáticas
con Pío y ya
entre tanto Ucrania Rusia Turquía y
Naciones Unidas lograron avances Durante
los diálogos celebrados en Estambul el
objetivo de dichas charlas es la retoma
de las exportaciones de granos a través
del mar Negro que es controlado por los
rusos el ministro de defensa de Turquía
aseguró que un pacto podría ser firmado
la próxima semana sin embargo los
esfuerzos por poner fin a la guerra por
la vía diplomática siguen en un punto
muerto veamos el informe
este avión aterrizó en el aeropuerto de
Estambul a bordo viaja una delegación de
expertos rusos ucranianos turcos y los
representantes de la ONU su objetivo
tratar de llegar a un acuerdo para
asegurar la exportación de cereales
desde Ucrania tras varios intentos la
confianza es baja especialmente para
kiev Aunque el ministro de exteriores
ucraniano espera garantías de seguridad
nos alegraremos de que los barcos
lleguen a nuestros puertos y se marchen
con seguridad para todos tanto para los
transportistas como para los
propietarios de los cereales y también
para nuestros puertos Pero para qué eso
ocurra tenemos que resolver el problema
de la Falta de confianza en Rusia porque
ninguno de nosotros Ninguno de los
participantes en estas discusiones
Confía en Rusia
por el momento Rusia sigue manteniendo
un bloqueo en el mar Negro que va desde
la costa rusa hasta la frontera rumana e
impide la salida de barcos ucranianos
para permitir el paso de los barcos
Moscú exige inspecciones y el desminado
de las aguas quien se ha negado hasta
ahora este último punto en el centro de
los debates está la creación de
corredores marítimos el tiempo para
llegar a un acuerdo sobre las
exportaciones de granos está acabando el
precio de los alimentos aumenta lo que
hace tener una hambruna especialmente en
África
Ucrania es el quinto exportador mundial
de trigo y el cuarto mayor exportador de
maíz el país también representa el 50%
del comercio mundial de semillas y
aceite de girasol por el momento 20 mil
millones de toneladas de grano ucraniano
siguen bloqueadas en los puertos de la
región de Odessa Turquía dice que tiene
20 barcos en el mar Negro listos para
embarcarlas Pero todavía no se ha
llegado a un acuerdo
y terminamos en Reino Unido donde se
realizó la primera ronda de votaciones
en el parlamento para escoger al
reemplazo del Primer Ministro Boris
Johnson de los ocho candidatos que se
habían inscrito ayer sólo seis lograron
pasar a la segunda ronda que se llevará
a cabo mañana pues no lograron obtener
el mínimo de 30 votos requeridos para
continuar en la contienda el exministro
de economía
encabezó la votación con 88 votos
seguido por la exministra defensa Penny
Morgan con 67
según las reglas que acordamos para esta
votación dos candidatos serán eliminados
Jeremy Hunt y nadie
los demás están todos en condiciones
para la segunda votación que se llevará
a cabo mañana Muchas gracias
así llegamos al final de las noticias
pero ustedes sigan con nosotros
[Música]